a former athletic trainer who accused
retired NFL star Peyton Manning of
sexual harassment is speaking about the
allegations in her first television
interview Jamie nor I talked with Inside
Edition anchor Deborah Norville na right
accuses Manning of inappropriate
behavior as she treated him for an
injury in 1996 Manning was a 19 year old
all-american quarterback at the
University of Tennessee he maintains he
was horsing around with a teammate the
interview includes never-before-seen
video of Manning's 2003 deposition
responding to a defamation suit later
brought by now right I briefly pull down
my pants to so-called moon him one one
second one and a half seconds pulled my
pants back up and continued with Jamie's
examination at the bottom of my foot
Peyton Manning has said he was just
mooning a friend what do you say to that
that's a lie I was repulsed I was scared
I was intimidated it was definitely a
predator intimidating anger violent eyes
that he had Manning's attorney said in a
statement Peyton Manning has been
absolutely clear Jamie and all rights
accusations are false when her claims
were first investigated 21 years ago she
told a very different story
her current account was invented several
years later in connection with her first
of several groundless litigations
against Payton most recently she left
Peyton's mother a vulgar and extremely
disturbing voicemail mrs. Norwich should
stop this abusive behavior Deborah
Norville is here with no rights first TV
interview about the alleged incident
good morning to you good morning guys
well this is very serious stuff and I'm
curious about what exactly did she say
happen and has her story changed at the
time she was a trainer at the University
of Tennessee and she was examining
Peyton Manning's foot and she said she
was down in a crouched position and he
dropped his shorts and placed his bare
naked backside on her face made physical
contact his genitalia touched her face
she says she pushed him away
an ugly word and that was the end a
different story than what she's telling
you no his attorney says look she's now
telling a different story
he says he was mooning a friend that's
what he says there were two other
individuals in the training room at the
time one of them said he wasn't in a
position to see what happened the other
has both have been questioned under oath
in depositions and he said this would be
Malcolm sacks and he said I don't know
why you dropped your drawers this was a
letter he sent to Peyton Manning but he
said he didn't see it as mooning but in
her 1996 affidavit not right she doesn't
mention physical contact at all that
detail then emerged as this 2002 lawsuit
yeah so to Gail's question does she
acknowledge that her story has changed I
would say it's become more detailed the
challenge is this she reported it to her
superior he said don't tell the police
don't tell the press she did however
call the sexual assault crisis hotline
in Knoxville the night of the incident
and in a record and there is a record of
that which you'll see in our report
today and in that report the person
taking the call said she feared for her
life she feared for her job however she
declined to give the detail she
preferred to do that in person there is
no record to confirm what details she
may have given at that time well you're
right that's an open thing was there
settlement there was she left the
University she filed an EEOC complaint
after this happened the incident in the
training room then doctor na Wright got
a new job worked at a college down in
Florida her career was going fine she'd
even taken the Olympic team to the
Beijing Olympics then Peyton and Archie
Manning published a book and in the book
after a nondisclosure agreement had been
signed when she left the university both
by her and Payton the book was published
and there was an excerpt that she
considered defamatory among other things
that said she spoke with vulgar language
and it mentioned in a particular
incident she sued based on the excerpt
in the book and there was a financial
settlement reached after the judge
declined to dismiss the lawsuit the
judge said quote there was sufficient
evidence to allow a jury to find the
existence of actual malice on the part
of defendants so there was a settlement
why is she coming forward now is she
saying because he violated the end
in her opinion correct why she's talking
correct and also the NDA now no longer
were many years later there have been
other legal discussions both parties are
now free to talk the reason this has
come up more recently as in 2016 a title
9 lawsuit was filed against a University
of Tennessee saying that there was a
hostile environment and sexual
harassment was going on this was
mentioned in that lawsuit and now more
recently Harvey Weinstein she says she's
inspired by the women who come forward
all right we can see more of your
conversation tonight absolutely thank
you to see what she has to say Deborah's
conversation today on Inside Edition you
can check your local listings that comes
on in different times in different parts
of the country Thank You Deborah thanks